hey guys I'm Michael I'm Evan thank you
so much for tuning into this episode of
middle-ground after the episode please
stick around for a word from our sponsor
or Skillshare learn how to get two
months of Skillshare premium for free
and hear about one of the courses that
is keeping me sane during my time in
self-isolation I'm glad it's keeping
using that but it is
I like it alright Bhama was a
representation of something important
Obama didn't do anything but an
abomination to us to this whole nation
yo
[Music]
what's the biggest misconception black
liberals have about you that we are so
hating we hate our mom we hate our day
we don't know history we're out of touch
is that we don't have any real-world
experiences we don't really know what
we're doing what is a misconception
black conservative people have about
probably that I have no moral character
I believe in chaos and anarchy no I
believe in I believe in the rule of law
I literally cannot comprehend the notion
of anyone being American and black and
having conservative views when you all
live behind a screen behind the black
mirror you could say pretty much
whatever you want do whatever you want
between you right here you got to be a
little bit more human
[Music]
my name is Kevin Martin I'm a business
consultant
I was born and raised in Pennsylvania
born into and raised in a conservative
household and I'm still a conservative
my name is Xavier I'm born and raised
Los Angeles I'm liberal hi I'm ELISA I'm
definitely as far left as one can walk
I'm Anthony Logan I'm from Virginia
originally grew up in a socially
conservative household but very
politically liberal I'm conservative now
and I'm looking forward to here are you
guys at the point of view my name is
Lady KTLA I am a conservative Republican
all right can I get my black liberals on
the left and my black conservatives on
the right say that again
liberals on the Left conservatives to
the right okay you agree with the prompt
you'll walk forward if not you'll stay
back
people need to get over slavery all
right so I guess I thought it over we
all know that slavery was a terrible
thing it was an atrocity
it was a human tragedy place we can't
just be talking about slavery every day
in India in 1865 this is 2020
we gotta press forward our ancestors
they both were like if they died for us
to be able to be here right now yes and
the best country on planet Earth yes
take advantage of what we have right now
rather than looking in the past and
saying oh well what was me because of
slavery you know there have been other
groups of people in slavery all
throughout the world they came to state
in that state so people a lot of times
they stay right in a place and others
are being able to pass them because
mentally they've moved on while others
have not because they used slavery to
put them in a victim mentality we can't
accomplish this because you enslaved my
ancestors slaves were taught English
slaves were taught how to become
managers and secretaries and cooks and
chauffeurs and
how to build water tanks and all sorts
of things we're here now yeah okay all
right
I really think honestly colonialism
didn't teach us anything because we came
from a society that was living and
running so I don't think we need to get
over slavery I think we need to talk
about the repercussions of it like
generational trauma like the system that
exists because of it I don't think we
should use it as a crutch take as
foreign governments foreign visitors yet
to hold yourself back you know what I
mean I think it is a mindset as well I
think one of the most dangerous aspects
of generational advancement is
misinformation I think a lot of young
people especially young men especially
young African American men and women
often have questions about why things
are the way they are why do I get
treated this way why has my mother going
through this or why does my grandma has
my grandmother going through this what
all comes down to the repercussions of
slavery and so I think that just getting
over something I think is just
absolutely ridiculous and so when I hear
people say that especially my fellow
African American people and Friends I
think it's ridiculous just getting over
something as serious as that I think
just plays into the whole idea of it
just didn't matter anyway so how long do
we can see you to harp on it how long do
we continue forever well we do we never
get over I don't mean educate educators
education is fine that's a no history is
one thing to not get over things right
you can't minimize slavery but I listen
to both of you and I even thought maybe
I'll stay out of this one but the notion
of ending the discussions on slavery
they haven't begun we just got the
lynching memorial in Alabama we just got
the african-american Smithsonian in DC
you cannot go to Germany and walk more
than a mile without seeing some sort of
tribute to the Holocaust some sort of
apology some sort of
marker the United States does not
acknowledge slavery in that way we are
beginning to discuss but we can't get
over it until white folks acknowledge it
being black should not influence a
political view
so yeah being black should not really
influence how you think politically
because what's good for us as black
folks should be the same as everybody
else
they're simply from the point of view of
me being an American and what embeds for
me in America I will vote for the best
person that is running and so far has
been in my situations been Republicans
conservative Republicans I vote based on
the issues that I care about and the
issues that I care about stem from my
personal experiences as someone that was
raised in a conservative household I
have different views on certain things I
have different views on pro-life and
pro-choice issues I have different views
on economic issues I have different
views on on trade and foreign policy I
don't think the skin collar should have
anything to do with a political view I
would say I definitely don't vote for
candidates just because they're black
ben Carson can never get my vote however
I do feel very much a part of a group I
feel like I have a shared history with
black people and descendants of slaves
in this country and so I do not vote
just based on what's okay for me I think
people should vote for what's in the
best interest of them and I don't think
that skin color should dictate on what
your interest should be based on skin
color
did you ever vote your religious belief
YES on abortion have I voted my
religious beliefs on abortion yeah have
and what's your religious belief on
abortion or even talking about abortion
it's nothing to do with this
conversation we have nothing to do with
this conversation
the majority of abortions are done to
the black race well I ask you should you
say interested in answering that
question really quick I want to ask you
because you said you wanted to leave
slavery behind you want to get over it
but how did I forget it yeah you said to
get over em so you don't let's not
forget it you're a Christian I still say
teach it you're Christian yes I am and
where'd you where do you think we got
that got what Christianity
Christianity goes all the way back to
the beginning of time so where did we
learn it though where we learn it well
the Egyptians had religions the Jewish
taught no where did we do we're meeting
Africa aspera in America you your
lineage yes
slavery right they've learnt it from
slavery their slaves also brought a
gentle with them when they came so it
was a mixture of everybody's religion
but they learned how to read so what
they what they learnt how to read was
the Holy Bible and either you gotta
believe the Holy Bible you're not we
knew how to be
I believe you're not every to reap what
Arabic what because it wasn't English
that's my saying I'm when in America now
everybody should speak English baby got
a speaking minute-
I support the black lives matter
movement
well I am a public defender for 17 years
I work in the criminal justice system I
see a lot of the behind the scenes when
it comes to police brutality so I'm a
strong black lives matter supporter grew
up in Compton my parents were born and
raised there even as a child when they
had the riots for Rodney King we had to
move to Hampton yeah it was something
that it was the first time I knew that
it was wrong the way the police how they
how they police the towns and his first
time I got a sense of injustice I'm just
interested since you identify as
conservative I was surprised to see you
come over and how that lines up with
your political views or maybe just what
your definition of conservative is since
the movement started I've been torn for
far too long we've had the police and
police on the right and we've had black
lives the african-american community and
the black community on the left and it's
just constantly it's just constant
fighting and so I support the movement
I support the agenda I support the
mission I just have not always supported
the way that that mission agenda was
being carried out I agree with the fact
that black lives do matter I think we
all agree on that yes nobody's gonna
deny but it's the tactics I don't like
the tactics I mean I'm sorry
in 2015 the Freddie gray situation also
with Michael Brown and in Ferguson
Missouri you burn in neighborhoods down
you're tearing things apart I have
people who will say well the percentage
of blacks that are being killed is high
and I said where'd you get that from
well we see it on TV all the time but
the ones who are not shown on television
is it a much higher bracket of being
shot quicker than a black man would and
that's shown with FBI statistics black
lives matter as an organization is about
peaceful protest and is about bringing
awareness there's no black lives matter
organizers who's ever looted a CVS
there's no black lives matter or
organizer who has ever advocated for
violence so in terms of saying look I
see somebody black on the TV who is
upset about the murder of a young black
male that's not the same as saying black
lives matter is therefore responsible
likewise I'm not sure which FBI
statistics but african-american men are
definitely the most killed by police
it's a very specific statistic police
aren't killing white folks like that we
can't just leave it there and say well
we were being killed more therefore it's
a problem with race why are we being
killed more by the police
is there a over-policed what is it more
police in our communities they mean it
means that the ratio the number of
police at any given time where I live I
am going to see police officers every
hour I'm going to see patrol vehicles in
a way that I don't see when I'm in
predominantly white neighborhoods
statistically and this is actually my
line of research black youth are seen as
four to five years older were seen as
scary were seen as intimidating so
that's why you see situations like Tamir
rice you see police reacting quickly
with lethal force you know he was but
there was no one there let's say he had
a real gun why couldn't the police say
stop he was killed in less than 15
seconds a twelve-year-old boy it was
pointing with a BB gun
had to be going that was their age and
they look real too and you know my
parents told me do not go outside with
that and I'm in the all-black area do
you now go outside what they and pointed
at people because a little real and
wiping it why can they did it hopefully
because they recognize that as a black
boy you're gonna be targeted you could
do a whole podcast on that one right
there I mean I'm going I want to go in
Barack Obama did good things for black
Americans
Obama didn't do much to black Americans
or for Americans in general but what he
did do was one very important thing that
I got to give him credit for and that
was the same day you can be black and be
the president of the United States it's
whole excuse oh oh I can't do anything
cos on black and slavery uh I'm not
trying to hear it no more you had the
first black president the black way for
the black kids all that good stuff for
two terms not once it wasn't a fluke two
terms Obama has done more damage to the
african-american race than any of the
other presidents he he came in to the
presidency lying
he lied to our faces to get elected then
once in he disavowed he just forgot
about the blacks first of all all of us
Obama didn't do anything but an
abomination to us to this whole nation
yo I mean I agree what you said you know
he did a lot of damage and the the main
thing that I remember from his term was
when he had black lives matter in the
White House Wow Ferguson was happening
while it was happened now you guys doing
a great job out there well you guys are
doing fantastic didn't say hey something
on the radio a little bit maybe because
we got some problems no guys doing a
great job keep on going so Obama was a
representation of something important
but also I think the whole thing is a
big puppet show and you know
hey brother I was I'm not I'm never
really sure what's going on behind the
scenes so we don't know what kind of
deals are being made I do think that
there was people that benefited from
some policies that Obama put in place
and I also believe that there were
people that did not benefit and so I
think that there are obviously good
things about the Obama presidency and
there's things that I disagree with with
you about the president's educate your
younger brother how'd you keep me yes
did you go to college yes
where'd you go Southern University at
Pepperdine what do you study political
science and law enforcement social
studies I mean what social status of I
teaching social science semesters it
shows the black community should accept
lgbtq+ rights I am not only a
philosophical conservative but I'm also
a religious conservative and I believe
that God made everyone in His image and
I also believe that we as Christians are
people to judge and so who are we or who
is anyone to deny someone their rights
as a person based off of what their
sexual orientation is or how they
identify or the lifestyle that they
choose to live you know I'm a part of
the LGBT community
I'm transgender so I was born female now
there's a no no yeah it was an
interesting Road even getting my family
to understand you know who I was at
times so I think it was like they didn't
want me for lack of better terms to have
another cross to bear which was what
they felt like it was another burden or
condition that would make me less than
but really intrinsically like we're all
born
okay Human Rights is one thing sexual
rights is a whole nother thing the
majority of the black community are
religious when it goes against their
beliefs ya know it shouldn't happen and
gluttony is part of the human race
people lettin too much and LBD BT XYZ
whatever their gluttony
all right now my viewpoint on a thing
about LGBT rights what are we talking
about exactly I want to be very specific
with this particular thing because when
I hear that I'm thinking about Dwyane
Wade saying he's 12 years old
difficult over old boy should be able to
call himself transgender is that what
we're going to do do we think that we
should have four and five year old
children on puberty blockers hormone
blockers because they think at that age
they're transgender you can't even get a
tattoo under the age of 18 you can't
smoke cigarettes you can't drink beer if
somebody wants to be gay trans whatever
as an adult that's fine not my uncle my
favorite uncle died of AIDS was gay that
was my dog wonder % if you gave us your
business I don't care that's you That's
not me that's you we're talking about
LGBT rights what do we mean I mean I
think it's the right to exist
Dwyane Wade's daughter knows exactly who
she is and she doesn't right and and
there's definitely research that says
that you know anybody under 25 years old
that your brain is not fully formed
thing is I knew when I was small right
as soon as I could
talk I was pretty much telling my
parents like these were the things that
I was feeling and I what I knew about
myself you know when you start to
self-actualize you start that at that
age you start at the early ages so if
you look at like psychosomatic some
children they start to voice and self
actualize in toddlers ages
we're just saying opening it up if
they're voicing themselves okay you're
voicing yourself and as a parent I just
you a platform to flourish and bloom as
you do and then when you're an adult if
that's the decision the parent wants to
make you can do what you want sure
that's the decision my parents said did
you kind of say what he's did so you
can't even like on the same page with me
that's like this this is what my parents
did you do what you want when you're out
of the house but the thing is if I had
the if my parents had the resources in
the education that they do now they
would have probably allowed me to they
would have offered me a decision that
would have helped me you know live my
life but you can't say that because it
didn't happen it didn't but it couldn't
be can now because we have the
possibility you know we have those
resources now they would have been yeah
yeah if they had the resources that they
have now definitely all you got to do is
listen you just listen probably the
first aspect of being discluded from the
black community is by the way I talk so
I was adopted to a Caucasian family I
was raised around in a completely
different culture and what most African
American people are raised in or around
or the black community is saying look
you don't believe like us you don't
think like us you know vote like us and
say you're not one of us
I felt I felt excluded as well you know
with the queerness transistor you know
when people get to know me and learn
that then there's like oh yeah I can't
be doing all that gay [ __ ] but like you
hear a lot of different stuff you know
being anything doesn't make you any less
black just by being conservative phrase
that I had coming up in the black
community people that I've known from
just being out and around in Virginia
some other kind of turned it back on you
or you want to support you want to
support chunk you hate black folks ought
to say in a third now I feel like
somebody that's kind of going away
because a person like me being a black
Trump supporter is less of a novelty at
this particular point now it's kind of
like a normal thing but we're not all
the same you know when I'm on the list
right have their own we are our own
people we're diverse group of people I
mean and I play hockey so a lot of
people are like black people don't do
that man I've never been outside of are
excluded from my race I'm cool with
everybody in my race and I'm cool with
everybody in other races I ran for
political office I've been member of
Park MOEA height Neighborhood Council
you win I did I represented Hyatt Park I
wanted to say something even though I
have felt excluded before black people
in my life have been the most welcoming
loving giving people that I witness you
know regardless you know my background
as well
so there's been two ends of the spectrum
for sure the reason why I came here all
the way from Pennsylvania to do this is
to show the world that even that all of
us regardless of our skin color or the
way we think politically we are so
diverse we're so diverse just because I
identify as a conservative doesn't mean
I'm agree with you or agree with you
just because you identify as a liberal
doesn't mean you're gonna disagree with
me on everything we found ourselves
agreeing with a lot today common ground
is here for this amazing crew here
that's us in all this work you know
great job that was that was intense but
that was a super interesting
conversation so kudos to you Michael for
an awesome episode Thank You Evan I'm so
excited to continue a conversation about
this episode and all the topics that
were discussed so if you want to
continue the conversation with us join
us on our Instagram live on April 6 at
12 p.m. we're gonna have more discussion
around this definitely a big thank you
also to our sponsor Skillshare for those
of you who don't know Skillshare is an
online learning community for creatives
where it millions of people will come
together to explore new topics the
skills ranging from illustration design
photography video freelancing and more
there's a ton on there and a class
that's keeping me sane right now and has
been super helpful is the productivity
master class create a custom system by
youtuber and author Thomas Frank the
reason I like it so much is cos like
look we're working from home
we're in self-isolation there's been a
ton of disruption to our daily lives and
the class has been really good on just
like helping me create a new routine and
bring me through all the basic steps to
find something that works for me given
my current situation which is the
situation that I know a lot of us are in
one of the best tips the class makes is
for blocking up your calendar for deep
work which Michael deep work what does
it mean to you do deep work is so
important I literally just need to turn
off from everything and just like ID
eight and focus on things that I need to
focus on to come up with new series 100%
one thing we have our directors do at
tribally is block off their calendar for
deep work so that people know not to
disrupt them when they're thinking of
all their amazing ideas that's just one
of many tips the class gives it's a
really great program and you can check
that class out and the first 1000
subscribers to click on the link in the
description below will get a two month
premium membership so you can explore
your creativity and more classes like
that so make sure to click on the link
in the description below for two months
of skill shares Premium Membership stay
safe stay healthy